The ongoing nature of television series means
they tend to spawn more fan theories than
any other form of entertainment.
Amid the ones that are absolutely ridiculous,
are some that are actually kind of plausible.
Let's dive down the rabbit hole and look at
some crazy fan theories that totally change
these TV shows.
Bikini Bottom: nuclear wasteland
In one popular fan theory, Spongebob Squarepants,
Squidward, Patrick, and all the rest of Bikini
Bottom's citizens were irradiated during atomic
tests, turning them into the bizarre characters
we see today.
“I don’t know what do you wanna do today?”
But how'd that even happen?
Well, the fictional Bikini Bottom is located
on the ocean floor under a place called Bikini
Atoll.
That name may sound familiar, because Bikini
Atoll was famously the site of 23 atomic bomb
tests in the '40s and '50s … including some
underwater detonations.
These explosions left the island and reef
exposed to massive amounts of radioactive
fallout, and Bikini Atoll remains uninhabitable
to this day.
Unless you live in a pineapple.
“Ohhhh, who lives in a pineapple under the
sea.”
“SpongeBob squarepants.”
The Paddy's Pub gang is way uglier than you
think
This awesome theory about It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia comes to us courtesy of a
Reddit thread from 2015.
In it, a user going by the name CraigsBenedict
proposes that Mac, Dee, and Dennis are not
really as attractive as they appear to us
viewers.
The idea relies on the "unreliable narrator"
premise, in which the story is told from the
characters' narcissistic perspectives, and
is not how things actually are.
“Alright, but you get my point your honor
and you can see that Mack was slowing down
at the end there and let the record show”
“Because he only works out his glamour muscles.”
“No, that’s, that’s bullsh*t.
I did like 3 more than you.”
There's also some evidence to back this idea
up: in the episode "High School Reunion Part
2," the gang choreographs an amazing dance
routine to impress all the jerks who teased
them in high school.
“Freedom, Freedom”
Of course, what they're actually doing is
this:
“Ahhhhhhhhhh”
If we take this theory seriously, it could
explain why the rest of the world treats these
three attractive people like total freaks.
Well, except for the fact that they routinely
act like total freaks.
“So, you guys ever eat cheese.
Cheese is a funny thing, cheese is a strange
thing.
I always wonder where what is cheese where
does ahhhhhhh.”
Professor Samurai Jack
In 1998, animator Genndy Tartakovsky was a
supervising producer on The Powerpuff Girls
for the Cartoon Network.
It follows the adventures of three superpowered
sisters, who were created in a lab by a guy
named Professor Utonium:
“I just wouldn’t want to touch it, yuck.”
“Actually, girls, to him, well, you are
pretty gross yourselves.
With your big heads, large eyes, little bodies.”
“Ok”
Then, in 2001, Tartakovsky created another
show called Samurai Jack, all about a warrior
ripped from the past and thrown into the future,
who wages battle against an immortal demon
named Aku:
“I am the last son of the land that you
have pillaged.
I am here to reclaim it, for my people, for
my father, for my birthright.”
Throughout the series, Samurai Jack wanders
around a dystopian, post-apocalyptic world.
And at one point, he makes his way to a ruined
city that looks kind of familiar...because
it sure seems to resemble the city of Townsville
from The Powerpuff Girls.
Not only that, but did you ever notice how
Jack kind looks a whole lot like the Professor?
Just what went wrong in Townsville?
Is this Mojo Jojo's fault?
“Haaaaaahaaaaaaa”
Ash is forever young because of a magical
Pokémon
Why is Ash Ketchum, the hero of multiple Pokemon
animated series, always ten years old?
Through 19 seasons and 18 movies, he never
ages.
Time definitely passes on the shows, because
Ash spends weeks trekking through the various
regions on his quest to collect badges and
become a Pokémon master, so by all accounts,
he should be at least a teenager by now.
The answer may have come in the very first
episode of the original series, when Ash witnesses
a beautiful bird Pokémon flying into a rainbow.
"What's that?”
“There is no data.
There are still pokemon yet to be identified.”
We later find out that this was a legendary
Pokémon called Ho-oh.
The games say that anyone who sees Ho-oh is
promised eternal happiness.
And since Ash's fondest wish is to forever
travel the world collecting and training Pokémon,
the Ho-oh granted this wish, giving Ash eternal
youth.
Sherlock Holmes and Spock are related
This is probably the best theory on the list,
since it might not simply be a theory, at
least in the eyes of Star Trek fans everywhere.
In Star Trek VI: The Undiscovered Country,
Spock — who, we must remind you, is half-human
— must solve a mystery in space...and to
do so, he relies on not only his Vulcan logic,
but his human ancestry, too:
“An ancestor of mine maintained that if
you eliminate the impossible that whatever
remains, however improbable must be the truth.”
And that's not the only time Spock relies
on the wisdom of his forebears, either:
“Are you actually suggesting they're from the future.”
“If you eliminate the impossible whatever
remains, however improbable must be the truth.”
“How poetic.”
If that quote's a little familiar, you may
be a fan of Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's Sherlock
Holmes novels.
The legendary detective first uttered the
quote himself in the 1890 story "The Sign
of the Four."
It gets crazier.
In the modern BBC series Sherlock, Benedict
Cumberbatch has said the line himself as well:
“Once you rule out the impossible whatever
remains, however improbable must be true.”
And then Sherlock and Spock finally met in
2013...kind of:
“You are suggesting the admiral violated
every regulation he vowed to uphold simply
because he wanted to exploit your intellect.”
“He wanted to exploit my savagery.
My name is Kaan.”
“The fly in the ointment.”
“Well, alright Spock just take it easy.”
Ah well.
Maybe someday we'll get the Sherlock/Star
Trek crossover we've all been hoping for.
Oh, wait.
“There can be no argument, the game is afoot.”
Never mind!
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
fan theories we should've added to the list...